Steve Kaplan: After the Normal World you have the What the F*ck moment.
The WTF Moment.
And that is the essence of the comic premise.
The comic premise is the idea that that something impossible or improbable happens, impossible
in the sense of a man living the same day
over and over again that’s impossible.
Improbable that a somewhat out of shape, not too physical analyst could be put out to the
field and do the derring-do that James Bond
would that is not impossible but isn’t improbable
[referring to SPY Movie].
So all comic premises revolve around the thought
that this impossible or improbable moment
happens and it asks the question what would
happen then and the best comedies then develop
that premise through character.
Paul Feig talks about how he wrote the script
for SPY focusing not on what funny things
he could do but what comic moments would come
out of character of simply putting Melissa
McCarthy’s character in these perilous situations
and then seeing how she would cope, how she
would grow, how she would become not only
a better person but a more fully realized
person of who she is.
So after you have the WTF moment, you have
what we call the Reaction.
Now in most comedies when the character is
faced with a life-changing, life-altering
impossible situation, most characters desperately
try to claw back to the normal world.
Now remember, in the Normal World your characters
are misshapen.
Your protagonists are not who they want to
be or need to be but they don’t know it.
They are unaware of it.
They turn themselves into a pretzel to try
to convince themselves that they’re having
a happy life.
That their life is O.K. and when the comic
premise occurs, that is all taken away from
them.
The rug is literally pulled out from under
their feet.
So in most Reaction sections there is a large
part of action that is denial.
The character is desperately trying to go
back to the way they were before this occurred.
In TROPIC THUNDER for instance the WTF moment
is Steve Coogan (the director) has taken Robert
Downey, Jr. and Ben Stiller and all these
other actors out into the country and the
jungle because they’re making a Vietnam-era
movie and he wants them to experience the
country (Nam) and he accidentally steps on
a landmine and blows himself up.
And while some of the actors (especially Jay
Baruchel) think “This isn’t part of the
movie.
This is not right.”
Ben Stiller, the protagonist of the movie,
is convinced that it is simply part of the
director plan and he keeps on trying to go
along and keep filming this Vietnam era movie.
So he’s in denial that this has happened.
In GROUNDHOG DAY, Bill Murray spends the first
day that he has relived in denial.
He says “Is this still Groundhog’s day?”
It’s only until the third day when he finally
starts to then figure out what’s happening
and how he can deal with it.
So the first part of reaction is usually denial
but the second part of reaction is starting
to cope with the new situation but without
any character development or personality development
or personality change.
For instance, Bill Murray in Groundhog Day
is kind of a jerk, so when he realizes that
whatever he does will have no consequences
for him he still is a jerk.
He figures out that he can go talk to a girl
and get some information from her.
He can come back the next day, he’ll remember
all the conversation but she won’t and he
can pick her up and have sex with her.
And thereby he has sex with all the women
in Punxsutawney after a time.
So you can see that he is dealing with the
situation but really without any character
growth.
For Melissa McCarthy, her reaction is both
pain and sorrow because she loved Jude Law
but it’s also anger and the sense that she
has to avenge his death.
Jude Law gave her this terrible piece of jewelry
that he put on a lanyard, a crazy cupcake
that he gave to Melissa McCarthy and of course
it’s a terrible idea to give this to a girl
that is in love with you.
But it becomes very important, symbolic touchstones,
tangible touchstones are very important because
you can say a lot with a little.
So at his funeral or the memorial service
for him at the CIA you can see Melissa McCarthy
taking out crazy cupcake ceramic kind of touching
it and you could tell that she’s trying
to hold onto Bradley Fine played by Jude Law.
In another scene at the CIA when they realize
that everybody’s cover has been blown and
there is this nuclear bomb on the loose but
none of her regular spies like Jason Statham’s
Rick Ford can go after it.
Melissa McCarthy takes out the crazy cupcake,
holds onto it and quite out of character jumps
out and says “I can go!
They don’t know me.”
Her reaction is that, even though she’s
scared and even though she really doesn’t
have any faith in herself.
Because of her great love for Bradley Fine/Jude
Law, she’s still going to do it.
So reaction is the moment when characters
are still trying to deal with this impossible
or improbable set of circumstances that they’re
now trying to deal with and what happens in
this sequence is your characters are given
simple tasks and missions to try to get where
they’re going to go or do what they’re
going to do.
For Melissa McCarthy in SPY, first she is
sent to Paris and all she has to do is go
into the office and spy on this bad guy who’s
going to lead her to other bad guys who are
going to lead her to the nuclear bomb.
It’s that simple.
She doesn’t have to become a super spy to
do that.
But because they’re on to her and because
they have blown up the office building where
she was supposed to be, one thing leads to
another and there’s a series of discrete
missions or tasks that she felt that she follows
one after the other that lead her on the path
to trying to recover the bomb, get the bad
guys and then avenge her love, Jude Law and
all the while she is doing this without her
realizing it, she’s changing because what
happens in a comedy (and you can argue almost
any movie, but especially in comedies) because
you’re starting with characters who are
more than flawed, they’re broken, there
is something wrong with them.
You can absolutely see there’s something
wrong Ben Stiller in Tropic Thunder because
he’s an idiot.
There is something wrong with Bill Murray
in Groundhog Day, he’s a jerk!
There is something wrong with Susan Cooper,
Melissa McCarthy in SPY because she’s got
no confidence.
She has no sense of who she is.
And because of this impossible situation that
they’re now going to have to react to our
characters that are transformed.
In a romantic comedy, it’s love that transforms
a character.
You know a psychiatrist will tell you that
if you marry a jerk, 30 years later you have
an older, fatter, balder jerk.
But in romantic comedies love is a magical
power that is transformative.
In Groundhog Day, it transforms Bill Murray
from a jerk into a really good guy.
And yes, he has to live through several lifetimes
to get to be able to do that but still…For
Melissa McCarthy in SPY what’s transformative
is even though she’s not aware of it, she’s
been able to come up with new powers, new
skills, and in reaction, is part of the movie
in which new skills that have been hinted
at in the normal world, new skills start to
appear.
QUESTION: What is the “all is lost: moment in Groundhog Day and at what point in the
movie does it occur?